Refugees are ordinary people who live through extraordinary times.
In the country they live in, conflict or persecution...
...have put them at risk.
They have no other choice but to flee and to leave their country...
...to seek safety.
This means leaving a lot behind,...
...one of the hardest decisions a person can ever take.
So what makes a person a refugee?
Refugees are no longer in their own country...
...and have crossed at least one border.
Ongoing conflict may put them at risk if they return...
...or they are at risk of persecution...
...because of their nationality, race or sexual orientation...
...or because they associate with a religion,...
...a social group or a political opinion.
Some get jailed or harmed physically or mentally.
Refugees often flee with no more than the clothes on their back...
...and leave behind their everyday life.